SPEAKER: Let me tell you a
story about moral hazard.
When I was in graduate school, my
officemate went jogging with his wife.
She twisted her ankle and couldn't
walk, which they knew was bad.
So they went to the doctor.
They said, we were jogging, she twisted
her ankle, and now she's in pain.
The doctor said, yes, that's bad.
You need an MRI.
Which they thought was
cool, because MRIs are cool.
So they went to schedule
the MRI and then
it turned out it was going to cost
them $500 for their deductible
and then 20% above that.
So the net cost was going to be like
$700, $800, which all of a sudden
wasn't so cool because they
didn't have that great insurance.
It was graduate student insurance.
So they went back to the doctor and
they said doctor, do we need the MRI?
The doctor said, no, you don't
need the MRI, wait a few days.
If you're better, you'll be fine.
If you're not better after a few
days, then you might need surgery
and you probably need the MRI.
So they waited, she got
better, they never got the MRI.
Had they had insurance completely, so
they wouldn't have to pay anything,
they would have gotten the MRI and
that would have been a moral hazard.
Care that they would have
consumed when clearly they
did not value the care
at the price of the care.